bitcoin lightning network uh and a lot
of what i think uh kind of you started
out and as you said in 2010 when you
read that bitcoin white paper and
economic freedom how do you think about
like the blue chip assets in the space
and bitcoin specifically and how that
has evolved since you first came across
that white paper bitcoin is kind of what
got me super excited about crypto in the
first place and i still am excited about
it i hold a ton of crypto or sorry a ton
of uh bitcoin um
but i think that uh you know it's gonna
it's it's gonna be around forever as
basically you know the gold or or the
money of this of this industry
um
i
i'm seeing adoption and an interest in
cro across a lot of different assets i
think that's generally a good thing you
know coinbase has always tried to be
agnostic about which one wins and which
one doesn't like we just want to
basically serve our customers with
whatever they want to do so it's been
actually it's i always am a little
frustrated seeing some of the tribalism
that happens on online and i always you
know twitter is kind of built for um
conflict and warfare and i don't think
it actually represents what the majority
of the industry feels which is probably
a much more nuanced view um which i know
you have as well
uh but yeah i mean bitcoin's great i've
it's been really cool by the way seeing
some of the lightning network adoption
just happening in el salvador with like
mcdonald's and all these things and so
um
i think i think it's great i think we
should keep building that stuff
is it fair to say in some way and i've
started to see this with uh folks who've
been around for a long time that bitcoin
early on was like incredibly
intellectually exciting and and they
really dove into it and pulled them into
this industry uh and there's almost this
sense of like inevitability to it like
you said you know bitcoin's gonna be
around forever uh and people who are
builders they start to become
intellectually interested in other
things as well doesn't mean they lose
interest in the original thing but just
like their uh aperture almost expands is
that is that kind of a fair way to think
about how your journey in crypto has
happened
yeah sure i mean bitcoin was a huge
breakthrough both in computer science
but also kind of economics and all these
things
uh but it spawned a whole industry and a
lot of other innovation that's sort of
derivative of that work and so i'm
always kind of interested in what's on
the frontier and um what's getting the
most adoption in different areas so i
think
we're quickly going to end up i mean we
already are in this world where the
crypto economy is built of a number of
different assets and blockchains that
have different purposes whether that's
to be sort of um gold or payments or
security contracts or
gaming or derivative you know so there's
more and more things that are going to
keep coming out i think we'll my guess
is that we'll eventually be in a world
where um there's maybe dozens of
blockchains but there's millions or
billions of tokens and you can imagine
all kinds of
things that people use those for right
every organization that comes out maybe
even every individual
or
these nfts and um all the stuff these
are all there's going to be so many
tokens that it's like kind of hard to
even imagine where that ends last
question on bitcoin is uh lightning
network you mentioned the adoption
especially el salvador obviously and
also corporations there um coinbase and
many other exchanges but uh coinbase uh
i looked before hasn't integrated with
the lightning network are there certain
milestones or things that you look at
you're like hey once there's a certain
amount of adoption or nodes or capacity
or something that then you guys would
say hey let's go do that or is it
something you're just kind of monitoring
and it's you know day by day is when you
make that decision
yeah you know so i was i was actually
asking the team about this earlier and
looking at some of the adoption stats of
you know you can sort of look at how
many how many bitcoin are tied up in
lightning channels and you can look at
sort of similar stats across other l2
solutions just to get a sort of a sense
but what i haven't actually been able to
find is a good
metric that just looks at um you know
how many transactions a day are
happening on the different l2 solutions
out there and i think generally
we want to be supporting all of them
that are getting some reasonable
threshold of attraction
um
you know but if there's one that's like
really breaking out then that kind of
helps us think about from a ux point of
view which where which ones to emphasize
um because i do think there's
essentially some sort of a cost or an
overhead uh for the for the average
person coming into crypto
like you know we need to expand the
circle of not just like super
sophisticated early adopters to like
what's the next level in the next level
so that's we need to get billions of
people into using crypto and so there's
a cost the more sort of jargon and
options that we throw at them in in
these interfaces um one of the teams
that i spun up this year at coinbase was
called the protocol team
and their whole job is just scale
blockchains okay that's like kind of the
the mandate of that team and they're
looking across all these different
things lightning and
the east solutions and and whatnot and
also just scaling it from um
you know how many taps do you have to do
to like complete a payment which i still
think has way too much friction
um but the more we can get that kind of
stuff working i feel like it's going to
be a huge unlock for the industry
you know how do we get like the next 100
million or billion people using crypto
we've got to get the throughput the
scalability increased i think i think
it's just like going from 56k modems to
broadband it's going to be
it's going to be an order of magnitude
increase in usage of crypto and
therefore probably the value in crypto
as well
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]